金ちゃん初めて超です皆さん僕がそう昔に出した動画
覚えてますでしょうかなんかめちゃくちゃでかい奮戦を使って昔動画落ち本当のところ
があるんですけど今回はそれの愛宗教かな
いやまだ先があるかもしれないので対象じゃないんですよ今回はその風船がさらに
大きいまでやってるんだと思います
もうこの辺でやることではないと思うんですけどねこちらね
サイズがですね140センチで僕パティ組んでブーブーパンパンに膨れますかね
一にフラワーして爆発したときに人という生き物はどういう反応するのか見ていいほど
思います出会いのおよび眠いですかちょっとだけ痛い公演だ列車です
実際強い店だけ
そういうのですか
0秒も見せてください
[音楽]
はい距離でターゲットが出てしまっているんですけどもここで早速空性を膨らませてみ
ましょう
イェイ
[音楽]
[拍手]
re too
[音楽]
お姉さん
mar
マンズリする子は初れることを願います
[音楽]
ブーブーレス f
yeah
[拍手]
car
kire nai no ni
rar
ai
ni
これ取れにゃんけど本取ってそれでございます
car
me
goo
ああああああ
yeah yeah
yeah
はあああ
ふぅんっ
hey はぁっはぁっはぁっ
うわーっ
r
海と言えばバーン
というわけでみなさんコバラサポートって知っていますでしょうか
医療があります御花さそふとってダイエットサポート飲料なんですけども
床が昔ダイエットしようと思った時脚使ってましてそして今回ですねなんとお花か
コート服や3+白桃風味という新商品が発売されました
人のふくらみプラスシリーズなんですけれど今までよりもさらに膨らみがアップした新
技術を使っているみたいでございます僕も巨大夫婦のふくらみ力をよりアップさせて
お腹の膨らみもアップしている
予定軍にはっきりを仕掛けさせて頂きましたそうだったんですね
ちょっと飲んでみます今変化まお店で買ってください
いただきますまあさっぱりする
飲みやすい甘いをとって膨らんできたような気がしますお腹も食うなんて皆さんの日が
復帰がしまっただけで面談としてよい
はい出雲だろう食べたいって言うその欲求に負けていた時もこうなサポートがあれば
無理なく食事量の調停やカロリーのコントロール
ができるんですだけでこのコバラサポート全国のコンビニな栄養ドリンクコーナー
ヤードなどなどとオンラインストアでも売っていますので
らしい2のそこのあなたはいぜひ試してみてください
上をやってたんですよねはい結構大丈夫仕えするのでよく噛んで叱らはい
そしてなんと今回あるを取ったんで僕のオリジナルグッズでついた
ほらサポート6本セットが数量限定で発売されることになりましたぁーっプレアデス
とても
オリジナルグッズの詳細は盗んだよなぁ6みてくださいって皆さん一緒に行く
音が入ってもうね
[音楽]
一緒に痩せようぜん
me
uh